so i don't know if it's going to end up
going out before or after this video but
i just got done filming a video about
strength endurance or work capacity in
that video i demonstrated a ton of med
ball slams
and as i was doing it i thought you know
what i absolutely love this exercise i
should definitely make a feature video
about them red bull slams are fun
they're extremely safe and they can
build explosiveness agility athleticism
they burn fat they're just fantastic all
round moves so i really think everyone
should incorporate them into their
training in this video i'm going to talk
to you about how to do them correctly
why you should be doing them and at the
end we're going to look at some
variations to make things a little bit
more interesting
and yes to answer your question it is
really cold but i can hardly recommend
cold exposure to you guys and then not
train with my top off because it's a
little bit chilly so the med ball slam
might look pretty simple and in fact it
is that's actually one of the big draws
of this exercise it's so simple in fact
that probably dates back as one of the
oldest and most ancient forms of
exercise apparently there is evidence of
you know primitive man slamming things
against the ground to get into shape but
the med ball slam as we know it actually
dates back to hippocrates who apparently
would stuff animal hides and get his
patients to slam them on the ground in
order to improve their general health
it's really hard to get this exercise
wrong it's a full body compound
explosive movement and yet there's very
minimal impact on the joints which is
just an incredibly hard combination to
find there's minimal loading and in
general it's really hard to hurt
yourself with this exercise and it's
something you can pick up and do and
even if you're not using the technique
perfectly correctly you're not going to
cause any harm and this makes it perfect
for training youngsters for people who
are new to the gym but it also has a ton
of benefits for those a little bit more
experienced as we're going to see but
what that apparent simplicity is hiding
is actually a hip hinge movement and a
form of triple extension but in reverse
it's like a reverse
explosive vertical jump because what
you're doing is instead of extending at
the ankles and the knees and the hips
that wants to thrust yourself upwards
you're instead flexing at them in order
to slam the ball back downwards
this can train you to get down into that
lower position much more quickly and
explosively which is fantastic if you
want to increase your vertical jump
because when you jump you first perform
something called a counter movement you
drop down to a low position and then
leap up the faster and more explosively
you get into that counter movement the
higher your jump is going to be so if
you can explosively move down you're
going to be much more explosive leaping
up at the same time if you perform a lot
of snatches cleans deadlifts then you
also need to be training this reverse
movement you're training all of the
antagonist muscles that you use in those
lifting exercises involve hinging at the
hips
this is going to help prevent injury and
to strengthen you those positions
because your antagonist muscles provide
a stability role in all of those
exercises and they help to decelerate
you through the movement it's going to
prevent imbalances and it's something
that many people are simply missing in
their training just a fantastic exercise
for improving athleticism speed and
explosiveness and this is a fantastic
metabolic finisher a great example of
resistance cardio because it's so safe
there's no impact not lifting a huge
amount of weight you're safe to do this
for high repetitions explosively quickly
and to really get the heart rate pumping
and if you've just performed a workout
for your lats in particular for your
core then finishing with this is a great
way to get in that work capacity to
train your aerobic system so if you want
to get your cardio in this is a great
way to do that not only because it pairs
really nicely with resistance training
but also because it's a whole lot of fun
and that's another great thing about the
med ball slam is that it's actually
genuinely enjoyable it's really
cathartic slamming something against the
ground and if you're someone who doesn't
enjoy going for long runs if you find
that boring then this is the kind of
cardio the kind of resistance cardio
that you might actually be able to
convince yourself to do
unless you think this looks like you're
not working very hard or it's not very
heavy try and do maybe a few minutes of
this at the end of your workout go for
10 minutes and see how you feel the next
day i promise you're going to feel this
in all the working muscles so what are
those muscles well actually this is a
surprisingly big lat movement and if you
perform a lot of med ball slams like
this then the next day you're going to
feel it in the lats in particular a
little bit in the shoulders as well a
little bit in the core but really we
shouldn't be crunching so you're going
to feel it more in the hip flexors which
is another reason this translates really
nicely to athletic performance because
it's going to help you to bring those
legs up nice and quickly nice and
explosively or you can do a little bit
of a squatch to pick the ball up again
which means you get a bonus air squat in
there which of these you do is going to
depend somewhat on which type of
medicine ball you get you can get ones
that are designed to bounce and ones
that are designed not to bounce if you
only get one i recommend the bouncing
kind because they're much more
convenient for a bunch of other
movements too like if you're bouncing it
against a wall or tree so how do you
perform the medicine ball slam well i
described it as a hip hinge movement and
this should give you a bit of a clue
this isn't a movement where you're going
to be really engaging the abs by
crunching at the core you're not going
to be flexing and extending the spine
all that much although if you get a
little bit of spinal extension at the
top and a little bit of flexion at the
bottom it really isn't the end of the
world so yeah pick up your med ball
raise it above your head
slam down and as you can see i'm not
crunching my core i'm keeping my back
relatively flat
and i'm hinging
at my hips
you want to bring it up over your head
you don't need to swing your arms back
behind your head just bring it straight
up above and then you're going to slam
it down as powerfully and forcefully as
you can and this is something else to
think about really focus on generating
force if you're just going through the
motions here then you're not going to
get the full benefit one of the most
common questions i get on instagram when
i show med ball slams is what weight of
balls should you be using and this is
going to depend partly on your gold but
what i will say is go lighter than you
think mine is only six kilograms this is
a rare exercise where adding more weight
doesn't necessarily make for a better or
more difficult exercise because here the
angle of resistance is actually going in
the opposite direction so the heavier
the ball the easier time you're going to
have slamming it down it'll be harder to
get it to bounce but but it's only going
to make lifting it slightly harder which
is interesting in itself but for
slamming it down
lighter actually works just as well
because i mean gravity is on your side
here that added weight is just to add a
little bit of drag so you can really put
in some effort so it doesn't bounce away
all over the place so that you slow the
movement down slightly but you don't
need to pile on loads of weight to get a
decent workout here and if you're doing
this for high rep ranges then yeah six
kilograms is absolutely fine 10
kilograms now one of the coolest
variations i really love with a medicine
ball is the power throw and all you're
going to do here is you're going to
perform the slam but in reverse what
that means is you're going to lob it as
far as you can behind you while still
exploding and getting in that triple
extension so this time you really are
effectively training the exact same
muscles you would do for a vertical jump
this is the perfect counterbalance to
doing lots of slams and in some ways
it's better than using a bar to train
these muscles because there's no risk of
injuring yourself you can't hit yourself
i cannot think about it i don't need to
think about a triple pull you know i can
just launch it up in the air
give as much power as i can and go help
a leather
[Music]
the only downside of this exercise is
that you then have to go and retrieve
the ball which means you can't do it
easily for a large number of repetitions
but if you throw it retrieve it throw it
retrieve it you can get a good workout
in
do though try not to crush someone's dog
people do not like that
another fantastic variation you've seen
me doing a lot is the rotational slam
and here you're going to slam against
the wall or something and you're just
swinging your body and hurling the med
ball into the wall it should bounce off
you catch it and you throw it back again
once again get a little bit of hand-eye
coordination training there make sure
that your wall is able to withstand
repeatedly throwing a ball at it you
don't have form little cracks like some
people might do
if you do this against the tree you
really get that hand-eye coordination
element because you just don't know how
it's going to bounce off the tree it
looks something like this
but the idea behind this is your
training rotational strength your
training movement in the transverse
plane which i just made a whole video
about with grant should check it out if
you want to learn more about this but
it's basically a whole missing plane of
movement for many of us we simply don't
train
rotation is extremely important when
you're throwing when you're throwing a
punch when you're grappling when you're
pulling or pushing something even when
you're walking and running you need to
rotate so the fact that we often don't
rotate in the gym is frankly tragic and
when you use a rotational throw you'll
be training somewhat the serape effect
which is this combination of muscles
that make a kind of mexican serrape
pattern across your body which is kind
of like a sling on either side the
serratus the obliques and this allows
you to twist and exert maximum force
this is the secret to how baseball
players can pitch a ball at 100 miles an
hour and how martial artists are able to
punch with the same kind of force as a
car hitting you so this is how you can
exert maximum force from your body you
of course should be training it this is
once again a fantastic low impact way to
train that even at a higher rep range
i talk in my video on strength endurance
about how many endurance adaptations
occur locally in specific muscles you
increase blood flow to the muscle you
increase mitochondria in that muscle you
increase your ability to recruit motor
units in that muscle so if you want to
get more endurance at an activity it's
not just enough to run as well as doing
that activity you need to do something
resembling that activity for a high
repetition in a way that's going to test
your energy systems
so if you're a martial artist and you
want to be able to go for longer in the
ring without gassing out then performing
something like this for high high rep
ranges is a great way to train yourself
to be more endurant in those movement
patterns another similar variation is
the shot foot throw where of course
you're going to throw from the shoulder
same rotational benefits involving the
shoulder a little bit more different way
of generating power
you can also do a slightly more
rotational version of the ground slam
[Music]
so that's the medaball slam i hope you
found this video useful and interesting
guys if you did then please leave a like
and share around that helps me out so
much and i massively appreciate your
support let me know in the comments down
below if this is a movement you guys use
or if it's something you're going to use
in the future and let me know if there
are other exercises like this that you'd
like me to feature in a future video i
genuinely believe that nearly every
exercise nearly every movement has
something to offer of course they have
my favorites though and this is one of
them if you like training this way to
improve not only your strength and your
appearance but also your mobility your
endurance your reflexes even your
cognitive ability then you might enjoy
my evoking training program super
functional training there's a link to
that in description down below and
there's a discount on right now
you might also enjoy my print book
functional training and beyond which is
a guide and introduction to the idea of
functional training and super functional
training for the athlete and for the
average joe
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys and i'll see you
next time bye for now